lawmakers in u.s congress have moved to
block president donald trump's order to
withdraw u.s troops from germany
it's a rare instance of the democratic
and republican parties
working together these days to pass
legislation
the final version of the annual defense
bill which
still needs to be voted on voices
support for the continued presence
of u.s forces in germany and
it would require an impact assessment
before any troops are pulled out
in july the pentagon announced it would
withdraw about a third
of the 36 000 troops based
in germany
well stefan siemens is standing by for
us in
washington stefan how likely is it that
u.s troops
will not be draw withdrawn from germany
now
um i think the likelihood just increased
actually it is very likely that there
won't be any withdrawal
at least not under the range of this
administration of the trump
administration as you pointed out
the budget defense budget
law package which is 4500 pages that is
a double whopper there
um is saying that they first want
congress
senate and and house of representatives
want to hear from the defense secretary
uh in a report about if this really
makes sense
if this is not harming national security
and
only after this report comes in and only
then congress will give it okay or not
and no more than 120 days
after this report arrives is any uh
troop reduction possible and now you do
the math uh this administration and
donald trump as president of the united
states will be 50 more days in power
and then it will be joe biden and his
administration and um
there is expectation by many many
experts and those observers here and by
anybody
in washington dc political washington dc
that
he will revoke this uh this plan to pull
uh or pull american troops out of
germany
okay this is a massive bill it contains
lots of of data and lots of steps that
donald trump may or may not approve of
could he veto this bill
yeah he actually already said he will
veto this bill but not
uh for that reason not because uh now
congress is uh putting another obstacle
for his plans to reduce troops out of
germany
or out of europe in front of him uh he
wants to veto is because he wants to
have
a law in this package which has nothing
to do with military budget uh
at all which regulates uh online
platforms like twitter facebook uh
google and so on because the president
feels that
they need to be now held liable for
for what for treating him and
conservative issues unfairly
and this is why he threatened to veto
this bill
stephan thanks thank you very much for
filling us in there that was our
correspondent stefan siemens in
washington
and joining me now from brussels is our
nato correspondent terry schultz terry
it was just a meeting of foreign
ministers at nato what did you hear
about this decision
there well gerhart this didn't come up
publicly at this foreign minister's
meeting and part of the reason for that
is
because the u.s actually has the right
to make this decision on its own
as president trump announced in the
summer what was disturbing for nato at
the time in addition to the fact that it
of course does not want to see any u.s
troops removed from europe is that there
was no consultation given
the german government wasn't warned as
nato secretary general
jen stoltenberg wasn't warned so there
was more concern about how this was done
than perhaps what what the actual
uh eventual movements might be but as
stefan just
explained there may be bureaucratic
reasons why it doesn't happen at all
and we got some hints about that earlier
this week ahead of the nato ministerial
from u.s ambassador kay bailey hutchison
she said that she expects this decision
to be made by the incoming
administration
and that's not all she told us about
what the plans may be let's hear from
her
i want to say that the announcement
about
troops in germany was also an
announcement that the troop
all the troops that were there before
would be
in europe it's just whether or not they
stay in germany or whether they
are moved to other places in certain
instances so that has not been well it
has been put forward but
it certainly will be open for
another administration to look at where
it is at the time
uh that they take over so in fact when
president trump made this announcement
he said very clearly that he thought he
may be bringing troops
home from europe out of europe back to
the united states and that is not what
the ambassador is saying now
at the time he said he may put some of
them in poland in italy uh here in
belgium
and now she's saying that there will not
be a reduction even in these paper plans
that may never come to be
that the u.s troop presence in europe
would be reduced so that's very
important for europeans to hear the
allies will be very interested to hear
that
uh but as again as stefan mentioned uh
the fact that this will be pushed to the
biden administration even by
bureaucratic hurdles
makes it much more likely we will not be
seeing a movement of troops out of
germany
at all terry should stand brussels for
us
thank you
you